here are three really messed up things
that happen to movie sets you may have
heard that Lemmings willingly jump off
cliffs to their own deaths this is
actually a myth propagated by the 1958
Disney film white Wilderness the
filmmakers reportedly pushed the
Lemmings off the cliffs to get these
shots plumbings weren't even native to
this area they like paid kids to come
bring the lemming so they could throw
them to their death and then say that
they killed themselves the filming of
fitzgeraldo was famously troubled it was
super remote and there was basically no
medical care and they were try braids
one guy got bit by a poisonous snake and
had to imitate his own leg there were
plane crashes there was a drowning but
some of the wildest details have to do
with the film star Klaus Kinski and the
director Werner Herzog the two had a
really tumultuous relationship and at
one point Warner planned to burn Klaus
Kinski to death they'd previously worked
together in another film where Herzog
threatened to shoot Kinski if he walked
offset finally we have the film they
died with their boots on where three
extras were reportedly killed on set one
of the extras were stunned people who
died was actually a man who fell off his
horse and was impaled on his own sword I
have a ton more so let me know if you
want to hear more messed up Hollywood
set facts in the comments